homework and I just had to call in to
say we had so much fun just laughing our
heads off
everybody around us is just doubled over
laughing I mean I've been to a lot of
shows but I've never laughed that hard
that a comedy show but genuine question
when you're up and look and I hate to
interrupt you but sometime the laughter
is it could better bring it out of you
it's that it's almost like an exorcism
but a good one it'll make something come
out of your a secret sometimes people
laugh so hard they they tell a truth
about themselves they let a secret loose
some guy the other day he laughed so
hard at the show and he's just like he
came out of the closet he's like ha ha
and his buddies like Patrick dude what
are you talking about Patrick have
another beer man your wife's gonna pick
us up in about 20 minutes do she's gonna
be pissed Rowe have two beers Patrick
and calm down bro you're gonna be fine
you got to get back to your wife and
kids man so you don't know somebody you
know somebody sometimes that giggle will
just wiggle something right out of you
it'll just shake a truth right out of
your frickin lie booth right out of the
back of your brain you did I killed
somebody with a shovel I love licorice
people just you know I don't wash my
husband's clothes but I tell him I do so
he's always wearing dirties you know you
just sometimes when that laughter get
you Lisa it can really shake something
out of you
it can shake the mainframe and that's
when maybe a little dribble of some
truthful just leak out of your feet you
know you suddenly suddenly you're
slipping a fact about yourself do you
never want it to admit I like to smell
my own ass you know something or
something like that you know sometime
you'll just a truth upon just will just
whip right out of you that you don't
want you know
I've been saving all my back hair that I
shave off in a bag under the sink in my
bathroom ah you know it just that's what
can happen might it smell like
tangerines so anyway a lot of truths and
and and and Nan and old secrets can come
just right just avalanche and out of
your freaking brainstem let's hear more
Lisa up on stage can you hear how hard
were laughing like are you able to get
that positive feedback from us because I
mean every sentence you were saying at
one point everybody was just dying
laughing man it was it was just
incredible so thank you so much for
coming to our neck of the woods
thanks for everything well you guys have
a beautiful neck of the woods up there
and Toronto and I and I never thought
Canada was real when I was young and
I've said that before drop my keys you
know I thought Ken I thought if you died
in Canada you woke back up in America
that's something that I thought or that
I'd heard or that I just thought and
then pretended like I'd heard you know I
thought maybe um or Canada was just a
place that they practice safety
equipment like if you ever saw a helmet
or some knee pads or uh you know if you
was at doing the bumper bowling and they
had the special lanes on the side for
the kind of kids that had a hit of that
Tisza more just youngsters that wasn't
used to push him ball and say all all
that's from Canada but as far as the
laughter goes you know it's really you
can what can you hear
yes sometimes I feel like I talked too
fast and I step on people's laughter in
a comedy club I'm so used to that I'm
more used to the area and so I know how
to manage that room size of a room
better when it's about 300 but in some
of these theaters you get upwards you
know a thousand two thousand it gets
tricky and I can't see anything when I'm
up there I could see maybe the first two
rows kind of and then it's just lights
it seemed like somebody you've ever been
outside and somebody's pulling a boat up
on a dock and you're like oh are they
gonna park this thing or they're just
gonna shine that light in my eye for an
hour it's like that it's like two people
are parking boats but none of them will
part they're just it's like okay park
your boat shut off the light or it's
like two motorcycles coming at you
diagonally and the lighter just hitting
you so you can't see if you kind of have
this light in your eyes so sometimes it
feels like you're performing - it's
almost like it's an experiment or
something like there's just you here
like a lot like a kind of like the sound
of laughter but mostly you to see these
two lights and you feel like you're just
performing into nothing almost it's
really bizarre
so sometimes it's nice at the end of the
show or some of the beginning the the
the light man will pull thee will bring
the lights up for a second and then you
can see everyone and it's it is a 180
from what you've been seeing the whole
time
so some of the people will react or do
something in the audience and if I don't
react to it I can't see I have no idea
what's going on most of the time but but
man it was so much fun there was one
moment where they brought the lights up
it was on Saturday I think and a man I
felt like I did I just felt people were
having so much fun and cheering it
manages
I don't know I just felt it doesn't feel
like it's for me I guess it just feels
like people are having a good time but
it just felt cool it was like wow this
is something just fun to be a part of so
I'm just glad you guys had a good time
Lise I'm glad you and your friend came
out and and enjoyed each other's company
you know there is something nice after
the show if I get to see some people and
stuff and just you know knowing people
had fun man it means a living good
afternoon and other times thanks for
watching that video you just saw I mean
it was okay but the next video you can
watch could be way better what if you
watch a video right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one watch this one watch
this one watch this one